first study very hard learn more things  it's not just a mark of heart if you  align martial art you have to learn  breakdowns gymnastic acting all kinds of  things yeah then just go to more fasting  one day your mind is a secondary shape  mark every Stan I do I'm free I'm not a  Superman and but I just tell myself I  gotta do it beginning do it for myself  later on I do it for my friends but now  I just to do it here for the movie so  this why I'm so proud of my movie right  now well let's see my movie right now  see from the master police story I'm so  proud of myself Wow  when I young I can do so many stunts a  lot of things I can't I cannot do it  right now so I'm proud of myself I can't  do it before yes I do scare I do scare  so many directly I want to work with Jim  Cameron Gilbert Lucas Martin Scorsese  Wow there's too many too many too many  tell me more I mean that's a lot from  Joe Gunn probably don't know who they  like who they are just too many thank  you so much love you